in so many areas were used nowadays to
questioning the status quo and exploring
alternatives it would be odd therefore
not to try to perform the same exercise
around marriage here seem to be our main
options for how to arrange our personal
roles first the standard match the
upsides are firm possession of one
prized person continuity resolution
children are reassured economic
stability and social prestige but there
are some downsides to sexual born
exasperation a lack of appreciation a
suspicion of better alternatives out
second option divorce now the upside
here are new possibilities for sexual
excitement and end two cycles of
acceleration and past problems can be
seemed to be all there for it the
downsides of it are at turbed children
economic chaos probably no one better
out there and in fact our form to the
third action the sunset clause marriage
may be renegotiated every 10 years now
the upsides of this are prospect of
sexual excitement much more appreciation
and effort and children who someone
where you Sean there are downsides to
insecurity jealousy terror of
abandonment no one actually might be
better and it's difficult to pioneer
there's a full affection marriage with
secret affairs the upside of this are
fragile stability mixed with partial
excitement but the downsides are deceit
jealousy cowardice a lot of shame
now what about the Pollyanna our fifth
action the upside here our constant
sexual possibilities and not much
day-to-day transpiration but they were
down some socially not very prestigious
a lot of jealousy around children might
be internal discontinuity exhaustion
career hails with a simple serial
nonbonding and Oconee the upsides are
lots of sexual possibility downsides
Moff evening loneliness Pacific a lot of
insecurities communal living here the
upsides are shared charming its sexual
variation but downsides though bit
utopian quite a lot of jealousy factions
and bickering and eighth choice celibacy
or the upside here are time to work and
think that there downsides to loneliness
sexual communication
[Applause]
see a recurring theme a struggle between
loyalty and freedom we can invest in
more loyalty but must then risk
suffering from boredom lack of
appreciation and central frustration or
we can invest in more freedom and risk
chaos irresolution
exhaustion jealousy and humiliation it
seems that whatever we choose is going
to be very painful the option is not
between error and happiness but between
what varieties of suffering we would
ultimately prefer this is why our very
favorite quote is Kiki guards playfully
Bleakley exasperated outburst from his
book either all marry and you will
regret it
don't marry you will also regret it
marry or don't marry you will regret it
either way
laugh at the world's foolishness you
will regret it weep over it you will
regret that to laugh at the world's
foolishness or weep over it you will
regret both believe a woman you will
regret it believe her not you will also
regret it hang yourself you will regret
it don't hang yourself and you'll regret
that to hang yourself or don't hang
yourself
you'll regret it either way whether you
hang yourself or don't hang yourself you
will regret both this gentleman is the
essence of all philosophy we do however
have one suggestion that humanity's
efforts should be spent not so much on
retooling the external structure of
relationships as on rethinking humbling
central problem with grappling with all
the wild beneath the surface while other
human beings are so hard to love and why
we are by extension so difficult to live
around in other words perhaps the answer
lies not so much in a new kind of
relationship as an improved capacities
around emotional skills the solution to
the dilemmas of relationships should be
to increase our understanding of how to
laugh rather than merely
easier to find and fire new lovers
[Music]
you